amazing to think it has only been a year
since you first heard about Fallout 4 at
this very event and thanks to you it
became not just our most popular game
ever but one of the industries it has
simply blown us away and we're
incredibly blessed to have fans like you
seeing what you've created not just in
the main game with the add-ons and of
course mods it is just incredible and
we're not done yet we're excited to show
you what's coming next
for Fallout 4
and I can
of course we didn't just announce
fallout 4 last year we also announced
and released fallout shelter which over
50 million of you have downloaded and
played we have a really big update
coming out take a look
we hope you're as excited as we are
about all of the stuff coming to fallout
we want to thank you again not just for
your support over the last year but your
support of our whole studio really over
the last 20 years there is something
else though that you've been asking us
about and yes we've been working on it